al parecer aquí nos piden hacer muchas
cosas y yo los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo ustedes por
su cuenta y después vean cómo es que yo
lo resuelvo aquí
dibuje un ángulo de 60 grados en
posición estándar junto con un círculo
unitario use el siguiente triángulo para
encontrar las coordenadas x y el punto
de intersección del lado terminal y el
círculo confirme que la coordenada de x
es igual coseno de 60 grados que la
coordenada aie es igual al seno de 60 y
que entre x es igual a la tangente de 60
grados permíteme poner aquí un círculo
unitario más o menos así
y por definición un círculo unitario es
aquel cuyo radio es igual a 1 así que
todos los puntos de intersección con los
ejes de este círculo va a ser igual a 1
vamos a poner la coordenada de este eje
x aquí es 1,0 en el eje y hacia arriba
la intersección la coordenada es 0,1
en este otro lado en el lado negativo de
las equis tenemos menos 1,0 y finalmente
aquí abajo en este punto tenemos cero
coma menos uno muy bien aquí ya tenemos
nuestro círculo unitario y nos piden
dibujar un ángulo de 60 grados en
posición estándar dentro del círculo
esto quiere decir que mi lado inicial
del ángulo lo voy a poner aquí en morado
va a iniciar aquí en esta parte
eje y se va a desplazar en sentido
antihorario así hacia este sentido 60
grados si este cuadrante mide 90 grados
60 grados es dos terceras partes por lo
que el ángulo terminará aproximadamente
aquí
el ángulo de 60 grados
este es el ángulo que me piden que
dibuje aquí de 60 grados
la posición estándar indica que va a
comenzar mi ángulo coincidiendo con el
eje de las equis y dependiendo de si el
ángulo es positivo irá en sentido
antihorario y si es negativo irá en
sentido horario lo siguiente que nos
dicen es que usemos el triángulo que se
muestra para encontrar las coordenadas x
del punto de intersección del lado
terminal con la circunferencia este
punto de acá suena bastante complejo
pero lo que dice es encontrar las
coordenadas x de este punto las
coordenadas
vamos a poner x en verde
y pongámoslo en
rosa
es encontrar las coordenadas de este
punto
aquí les doy un tip podemos crear un
triángulo rectángulo al dibujar una
línea recta que baje de el punto de
intersección hacia el eje x de manera
perpendicular vamos a dibujarlo aquí de
este punto de intersección hacia el eje
x de manera perpendicular
aquí tenemos nuestro triángulo
rectángulo este va a ser un ángulo recto
de 90 grados también sabemos que si
tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados y uno de
90 grados el ángulo restante será de 30
grados este ángulo de aquí arriba valdrá
30 grados
ya que la suma de los ángulos internos
de un triángulo debe ser igual a 180
grados
usando esta información y este otro
triángulo de acá y conociendo que ambos
son triángulos similares podemos
encontrar los valores de xy pensemos en
ello la coordenada x es simplemente la
longitud que hay desde el inicio del eje
hasta dónde termina este lado del
triángulo esa longitud será mi
coordenada x por otra parte esta altura
de este lado del triángulo será
equivalente a mi coordenada y pues va a
ser el valor de este punto de
intersección así que este lado será el
valor de mi coordenada en g si
encontramos las longitudes de ambos
lados vamos a encontrar los valores de
estas coordenadas también sabemos que
estos dos triángulos son similares aquí
tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados aquí
también tenemos un ángulo de 60 grados
aquí tenemos un ángulo de 30 grados y
aquí también hay uno de 30 grados y por
supuesto nuestro ángulo de 90 también
está en ambos triángulos
los ángulos son iguales entonces
tendremos triángulos similares por lo
tanto las proporciones de sus lados
serán iguales que las dos conocemos
dentro de este triángulo de aquí del
círculo en el otro triángulo nos están
dando todos los lados y todos los
ángulos bueno en este lo que sabemos con
certeza es la longitud de la hipotenusa
de este punto a este punto ya que es un
círculo unitario y este es un radio por
lo tanto en este lado medirá uno veremos
si podemos usar esta información para
encontrar la proporción entre los lados
del triángulo por una parte podemos
decir que la proporción entre el lado
más corto y la hipotenusa y el triángulo
este que nos están dando comodato deberá
ser la misma que la proporción entre la
hipotenusa de este triángulo dentro del
círculo y este lado opuesto al de 30
grados así que la razón entre
el lado más chico que vale uno entre la
hipotenusa de este triángulo externo
debe ser igual a la proporción de este
valor de x que es nuestro lado pequeño
que estamos buscando x
entre la hipotenusa pero aquí nuestra
hipotenusa de este triángulo es 1
por lo que x va a ser igual a un medio
este valor de acá abajo de este lado
será igual a un medio ya encontramos un
lado usemos la misma lógica para el otro
lado tenemos que la proporción de este
lado raíz de 3 raíz de 3
entre la hipotenusa de este triángulo de
afuera debe ser igual al valor de este
lado y
entre la hipotenusa de ese triángulo que
es 1 por lo tanto que va a ser igual a
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 de este lado
y va a ser igual a raíz cuadrada de 3
entre 2
ahora ya conocemos las coordenadas x así
que esto que puse acá lo puedo sustituir
el valor en x que es un medio con un
medio y el valor en que es de raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 2
la última parte nos pide confirmar que
la coordenada en x es igual al coseno de
60 grados y que la coordenada de jett es
igual al seno de 60 grados además de que
ye / x sea igual a la tangente de 60
grados usamos nuestro soca tohá vamos a
escribirlo sol
todas para encontrar esto para encontrar
el goce no usemos acá que nos dice que
el coseno de 60 grados es igual al
cateto adyacente que el adyacente es x
medio
entre la hipotenusa que es 1 así que
esto será igual a un medio que es igual
a nuestro valor en x esto ya lo checamos
que es cierto
ahora para comprobar el pse no vamos a
usar solo eso nos dice que el seno de 60
grados esto también son grados es igual
al cateto opuesto el opuesto 60 grados
es raíz de 3 entre 2 raíz de 3 entre 2
entre la hipotenusa que es 1 entre 1 por
lo que el seno de 60 grados es igual a
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 que es el
mismo valor que tenemos acá esto ya lo
comprobamos
nos piden comprobar que ya entra x es
igual a la tangente de 60 grados de
todas
vemos que la tangente de 60 grados es
igual al cateto opuesto entre el cateto
adyacente que nuestro ejemplo nuestro
cateto estoy bien y nuestro cateto
adyacentes x por lo que esto es igual a
ye / x que es lo que nos piden comprobar
esto también es correcto